yeah I saw a demo for The Last of Us I
don't know if you can hear it behind me
this microphone might be just a little
too awesome but like just you just hear
gunshots and these dying behind you what
I love about this game is we just sat in
a theater and we saw someone play the
game so we didn't actually get to play
it but they got to show us you just hear
murder behind me it's fantastic they got
to show us the elements of the game and
it really concentrates on stealth and
there are a lot of stealth games out
there it's always one of those alright
it's a stealth game I'm gonna go in hide
if I get seen and it's fine I'll just
waste a couple people this one really
showed how imperative it is to be
stealth Lee you really feel like you're
in this post-apocalyptic world if you
have a revolver with four bullets in it
if you screw up yeah well you got to use
your pipe and beat the [ __ ] out of a guy
just whack him over the head with the
pipe
I'm telling you this was the most
enjoyable demo I have seen not just to
mix this packs but a couple of paksas
get ready
you're sneaking around you have this
little girl you need to protect her and
the guy he was chasing the dude the dude
went around the corner he wasn't there
he was like where the hell is he the
enemies will actually start hunting you
it's you just have your eyes you have
your eyes your ears you don't have a
radar you don't hang you don't see
little dots on a little map where the
guys are you just have your senses with
you and people are hunting you you're
hunting them if the apocalypse is now
it's one of those apocalypsis I wouldn't
be looking forward to it like everyone
wants the zombie apocalypse to happen
it's one of those apocalypse as I'll be
like I'm fine where I am now with
technology and civilization I don't want
the zombie apocalypse if it ends up like
this I'm looking forward to this game
this is one of my most anticipated games
easily up until this point The Last of
Us I'm telling you check it out is
badass